[Musique]
la production sirop d'érable bat son
plein ces jours ci au bas saint laurent
la saison a débuté avec un peu de retard
mais dans la grande région de montréal
les plus au sud la récolte est bonne
très bonne même ça tombe bien parce que
les réserves elles n'ont jamais été
aussi basses
[Musique]
on l'a baptisé leur bureau le terme est
bien choisi c'est la production du sirop
d'érable a longtemps eu un caractère
artisanal elle est devenue une
importante industrie qui contribuent à
l'essor économique de plusieurs régions
du québec
la province est le plus important
producteur de sirop d'érable au monde
est là sur 72 % de la production est 5e
le cerro coule à flots il ya de plus en
plus de séries cultes heures au québec
on compte maintenant 13 mille 300
producteurs et 8000 érablière ils sont
répartis dans 12 régions de la province
d'autres provinces profite aussi des
largesses des érables à sucre le nouveau
brunswick produits 4% de tous le sirop
d'érable canadien l'ontario 3% et la
nouvelle écosse 1%
[Musique]
au printemps 2000 21 les acériculteurs
québécois ont produit 133 millions de
livres de sirop une baisse de 25% par
rapport à l'année précédente mais faut
dire qu'en 2020 la récolte avait atteint
un niveau record de 175 millions de
litres l'or liquide est précieusement
gardés dans une véritable forteresse la
réserve mondiale de sirop d'érable
située à laurier ville dans le centre du
québec ce gigantesque entrepôt à une
superficie équivalente à cinq terrains
de football on peut y entreposer jusqu'à
94 mille barils de 200 5 litres la
réserve permet de gérer les stocks de
sirop d'érable en fonction des
fluctuations de la récolte quand la
production dépasse la demande les
surplus sont entreposés dans la réserve
et comble la demande quand les érables
sont moins généreux ça garantit un
approvisionnement constant comme les
affaires sont bonnes dans l'industrie
acéricole la construction d'un second
entrepôt doit débuter ce printemps
mais en février dernier la réserve
mondiale s'est retrouvé à son plus bas
niveau depuis 2008 avec à peine un peu
plus du tiers des stocks de sirop
d'érable habituel pourquoi parce que
depuis deux ans les ventes et les
exportations ce héros grimpe en flèche
une augmentation d'environ 20 pour ça et
selon les prévisions les ventes
devraient atteindre 185 millions de
livres d'ici 2023
les américains ont la dent
particulièrement sucrés environ 60% de
notre or blond leur est destiné 9 % de
la production prend le chemin de
l'allemagne 6 % et vendus au royaume uni
l'australie et la france achète
respectivement 5 % de notre sirop et le
japon près de 4 et demi pour cent
les ventes de sirop d'érable biologique
en particulier sont en très forte hausse
le nombre de producteurs bio a triplé
ces dernières années passant de 380 600
en 2015 environ 1300 producteurs mais
c'est pas encore suffisant pour répondre
à la demande comme la demande pour l'or
blond est en croissance les producteurs
et productrices acéricoles du québec
l'association qui regroupe les
acériculteurs a décidé d'augmenter le
nombre dans ta y donc de produire plus
en 2021 l'organisation a procédé à
l'attribution et au tirage de 7 millions
d'enfants supplémentaires d'ici 2024 une
partie servira au démarrage de nouvelles
érablière et l'autre permettra
d'agrandir des érablières existantes ça
portera à 57 millions le nombre total
vantail dans la province enfin ce
printemps les acériculteurs font face à
certains défis par exemple
l'approvisionnement contenant de métal
est difficile et les coûts de production
grecque est-ce que ça risque de faire
grimper le prix du sirop d'érable en
principe non parce que les conditions de
vente sont négociés à l'avance et repose
sur une entente de trois ans qui se
termine à la fin de 2022 on devrait donc
pas payer plus cher cette année pour se
sucrer le bec
[Musique]